hi I'm back and I'm also silver at and
you might notice that something's
changed about my game obviously the
ground textures are a bit different and
you can see that well it's most obvious
when you look at my paths because
they're more greyish than the very
orange like brown they were before now
that is because Old Spice released a mod
that changes the game textures so for
example this used to be some old I don't
know what kind of it was some soil sand
ish texture but now it's this and we've
got some more flowery grass and other
cool stuff I think this one's really
good as well this one's cool and
basically he changed all of the textures
in the game so I installed it and it
automatically changes the textures of my
paths and the grass I have around well
basically all the scenery and also the
textures underneath here actually
doesn't look that bad now I didn't know
what to expect I was actually expecting
that it would screw everything over but
it didn't
it still looks okay now I I am not even
sure if I like it more like this or more
like the way it used to be the grass and
sand obviously are a lot better than the
end game once but the path is maybe a
little bit too Brown I don't know
so leave a comment if you think I should
change it if I should well make it more
brown reddish and also leave a comment
if you think it's good this way so
anyway I'm going to continue on building
in this area of the park because I need
some buildings in here
Oh
Hey ouch again yet proven
[ __ ] just approve
so I'm getting there with this but yeah
it's not quite finished but just a few
things first of all I was pretty pissed
after I just finished this because I
recorded everything did all of the
supports minimized my game to look at
Skype and then game was like crushed and
I was like I didn't save because I'm
because I'm stupid so lost all of my
stuff so I need to reopen the game make
all of the supports again be like safe
this time minimize my game try to open
it again
crashes restart my computer open the
game minimize it open it again crashes
so yeah I am NOT going to accuse anybody
falsely for this but I think that there
may be some bug in text mod or spices
mods with them something like that
because ever since I installed spices
new textures I got this bug and this is
quite heavy for me because I need to
record in full screen modes in order to
have maximum resolution otherwise - lets
play quality's going to be very low and
yeah I sometimes need to minimise my
game just so I can
yeah do other stuff so yeah I just got
rid of the textures yeah yeah yeah I got
rid of the textures in the as you can
see it's all working in gamey and boring
right now but that's just because I
don't want any crashes right now so I'm
just going to do it like this and then
at the end when I'm getting to record
open up text mods
use the mods on rollercoaster in three
and it's all going to have a happy and I
hope somehow but that's it and this
coasters not finished the only thing
that I really still need to do is
finishing touches like finish this
little blouse on here have some nice
flowers I really want to have a lot of
flowers and nice trees because now it's
looking way too bland and batches of
course lights and I might want to fix
the cue line because it's looking very
boring and unrealistic right now so
somebody told me that he would explain
to me somehow how I could make a good
cue line so I guess it's all going to
work out someday
so until then peace out and see you see
you next episode I'm off again for now
and see you next episode in which I'll
do these finishing touches and maybe
start making another flat ride or
something